Okay.
Jocko many times he said that liking a
fight or liking to fight should be a part
of every man's personality.
Could you expand on that?
I've always been
interested in martial arts,
but I've always been reluctant to
fight and I would do anything not to.
Does that make me less of a man?
So obviously this was pretty
fitting question for the situation.
So this is obviously a good
question. Uh, and a fitting question.
Talking about being a man.
Uh,
I don't know if I said liking to fight
should be a part of everybody's every
man's personality or if I said that it
is part of every man's personality and,
and it, I think I said is part of
their personality. And if I said that,
what I think I should have
said is most right? Most men,
uh, have in their personality some
level of interest of fighting,
right? We wrestle, we box, we scrap
as kids look at the UFC. Right?
Why is the UFC so popular right now?
Because it's fighting and we have that,
that's a,
I read the other, that's a $7
billion organization. That's,
there's a lot of people
watching those fights.
A lot of people want to watch those
fights. We have boxing, we have wrestling,
we have Jujitsu, we have
Judy, we have Moitai.
We've got all kinds of
martial arts schools.
So while I don't think the desire to
fight is inherent in all men, right?
I'm sure there's men out there
that have not into it at all,
but I think it's definitely a,
a pretty strong part of many men
now for this individual, particular,
um, do, do I think that being reluctant
to fight makes you less of a man? No,
actually I think it's fine. The,
you should be reluctant to fight.
I think everyone should be reluctant,
but there's a lot of bad things that can
happen in a fight. A lot of bad things.
You know, first of all, you can
get hurt, right? That's bad.
You can get seriously hurt. You
can get killed, you can get killed.
You can get punched one time,
fall down, hit a curb and die.
You can think you're going to
get in a fair fight with someone.
They can stab you in the neck and kill
you. Right? These things can happen.
Even if it's not that bad, you can hurt
someone else. Now you're getting lawsuit,
now you're getting put in prison. Right?
So there's all kinds of bad things.
So being reluctant to fight is actually
a good thing and it's something that men
should have. And actually the
more you know about fighting,
the more reluctant you will be.
I was way,
the less I knew in my life about
fighting the more, or sorry,
the more I actually knew about fighting,
the more reluctant I became to fight
cause I realized all the risks that are
involved. Part of that was maturity. Sure.
But the reality is you look
at someone and you go, Whoa,
I don't know who that person is.
A they, they might be training.
I'm over here thinking I've been
training Jujitsu for f eight months.
I'm ready to kick this guy's ass.
Meanwhile,
you don't know that guy as a purple belt.
Guess what's gonna Happen to you?
You're getting crushed.
Or that guy wrestled in high school.
He's about to double leg you
and slam you on a curb. Yeah,
you're going to die you.
So you should be reluctant to fight.
That's a good thing. Now, that being said,
I do recommend that you
are prepared to fight.
I definitely recommend that, and there's
going to be a big dichotomy here.
I'm gonna get to, but you
should know some basics, right?
You should understand threats. You should
know how to contend with other people.
You should. You should know some
boxing. You should know some wrestling.
You should know some boys.
I should know some Jujitsu for sure,
because here's the dichotomy. This
is the, this is a big dichotomy,
and think about it. It's 100% true. This,
this individual says he would
do anything not to fight,
would do anything not to fight.
Let me tell you,
the best thing you can do as a human so
that you don't have to fight is actually
learn how to fight.
That is the best way to not have to
fight as if you know how to fight.
If you know how to fight,
people aren't gonna want to fight you.
You don't even have to say anything.
They can tell.
You can tell when you meet somebody. You
can tell if that person, oh, if you're,
if you're ready to fight,
people don't want to fight you.
The more eager you ought to fight,
the less people want to fight you.
If you don't know how to
fight and and bullies,
because that's what we're talking about.
Bullies see that you don't want to fight.
Guess who they're coming after.
You now guess what?
Now you have to fight.
But if you know how to fight and you
have that confidence and you have that
understanding and you learn simple
things like avoidance and you learn,
you have better situational awareness,
you become a threat to the
people that want to fight you.
If you become a threat to them just
by just by your knowledge alone.
So No,
you're not less of a man because
you were elected to fight.
You actually should be reluctant to fight,
but you should learn how to fight
because the best way to avoid fighting,
the more equipped and
prepared to fight you are,
the less you will have to fight,
the less you will be put in positions
where you have to fight and the better the
outcome will be if it
does happen to occur.
Yeah. Yeah. Interestingly,
like a lot of the people
that you meet in Jujitsu or,
or just like this where I'm interested
in martial arts but I'm not interested in
fighting. No, for sure. For sure.
And then they learn and then I get,
well there's a strong
component of nerds in Jujitsu,
right? Strong component.
Really strong of of,
you know I'm saying it jokingly,
but there's just a studious type students
type people that aren't super physical
there. More cerebral than
they are physical. There's
a ton of people like that.
And you know what? They'll do choke you
out. They will end up being real good.
Yeah. They wind up being real good cause
they're like, Oh I, I understand this.
There's a,
this is a game that I can learn.
And then I can crush and that's good and
now I have more confidence on him for
worry about it anymore. Again. It's
interesting how that third or that,
that additional element that they're not
really used to like how you say nerds
and you know, we'll just say like people
who are more cerebral within physical.
Yeah. It's that maybe they didn't play
high school sports, right? Yeah, totally.
We're studying because they
were working on a computer,
right? Yeah. Cool. Right on.
Yeah. They were playing music,
right? Yeah. Whatever. Yeah.
And then now they get into this highly
physical situation cause just to,
let's face it, that's physical.
That's your whole body.
It is physical as well as the book can
be and but you get in and you're just
finding success just by learning it.
It's not like football where it's like,
sure I know how to catch.
I can't run fast though and I can't,
I'm not big and strong or whatever, so
I'm just getting smashed, you know, I can.
But this,
it's kind of like the more you know,
the better you are kind of thing and sure.
Physical attributes help you for sure.
But even that much, yeah, there's,
there's you being stronger as great.
Yeah. You know, Dean was talking
about the city on the map.
The stronger guys not always going to win.
The more athletic guys not always
going to win. Sometimes they do.
There's various categories
that will bring you a victory.
One of the strongest categories that
you could have. Well the, this strong,
the strongest category is your technique
because no one wants to do because no
one wants to do.
And so you're smart people,
your cerebral people that come
in and go, oh, I can apply,
I can apply this knowledge the same
way I apply my skills in accounting.
James Nielsen, world's toughest
accountant, he's an accountant,
he's a back.
So that's just the reality and yeah,
and that's why, so now they're in,
that's why people get addicted to,
because it's like this element of
physicality, like a physical fighting,
more fighting sport by the way, combat
sport. And now they're in the end,
they're good at,
they're good at something physical for
the first time and they're still smart as
smart can be. You know,
like they always were.
So now they got that and that
additional, um, like pay off, you know,
that's where they get it
to additional power. Yeah.
I recognize that with the
kids that come to Jujitsu,
the oftentimes,
and it's not an always,
oftentimes the kids that get really into
Jujitsu are kids that are smart and,
but they haven't done a
lot of other sports yet.
And it's exactly what you're saying.
It's very noticeable with kids.
The kid that played baseball his
whole life and he comes in there,
he actually doesn't like it at first
and maybe doesn't even want to do it
because he's getting choked by someone
that seems all nerdy to him. Yeah.
And he knows I could throw a baseball
further than this guy and so it makes him
mad and he doesn't want to train.
Yeah.
But oftentimes it's the kids that come
in that really haven't done too much
athletically and you know, they're,
they got picked on. We got, we've,
I've had a lot of bullies come to mind,
Jujitsu kids program.
The reason they're there is
because they got bullied.
And once I started training six months,
they're not getting bullied anymore,
and a year later they're a different
person. Yeah. There are different kid,
confident, assured themselves not
backing down, not being jerks,
not being bullied themselves, but
just confident. Yeah. So yeah.